bastards
let's go with uh owen stalker i'm in a
good mood today i don't wanna
tom mcdonald's gonna put me in a sour
mood all right
okay check this out so she's still just
there traveled back into this oh yeah
yeah
she's still hiding that's a just
standpoint idaho
she lives here now past
like back to my hometown pretty town
in new york free of course it's a pretty
town i i like
old towns like that
where owen came from and then we both
end up in california
southern california
and then oh man you know what's sad the
industry's gone there you saw the like
for sale signs and
we both end up in washington really
close
like no no no you both didn't end up in
those places
you're following him like he's the
grateful dead you really do selling an
ex that's stalking
oh wow you shop here too and it's like
you live in lakeland
what are you doing here are you really
driving to fort myers to go to the
publix like oh
you shop here like only a couple hours
away from each other
and then we end up in sewing point even
closer together
but because you followed him
the fact that she keeps to end it up
would just ended up it
we always end up here at the same place
at the same time
what are the odds very high
if you're following him yeah very high
when he puts his p.o box in his video
description and you drive to that post
office
come on guys what she's covering the mic
of course the signature move
go to the post office and go is there
have you seen a really tall
guy here ranting about on the moon and
they're like yeah he comes in every
other day
yeah he'll be here probably like three
o'clock i'm here to collect this mail
can i have it
and then she finds his house identified
mostly is
check you know slovakian
isn't that true is that her car oh this
is her car that she's living in
no are you sure yeah doors open look oh
okay
but i saw this look at the blanket and
stuff in there okay yeah cause i saw
that the old man was also walking so i
didn't know if that was his car yeah
look at all that crap
yeah yeah that's that's that's her sort
of shirt is there just a bucket of
chestnuts in the back backseat
isn't that trippy oh what the hell no
caddy
i'm pretty sure the maniac is living in
his cars
you know the voices in the maniacs head
the best line in that episode is
you know you guys are good guys you
remind me of my sons
oh you have kids not anymore
it's like the best he was so great in
that video
and they're like i'm starting to think
this guy is a legitimate maniac
so look at this they got old cover the
mic theaters this is ritzville
washington i just went in that little
thing washington what caught some
glasses so i could do my
billy goats impersonation when i get my
lavender sweater
so i can come hypnotize
i'm gonna go oh y'all she is in
ritzville i'm i
if you type in rootsville washington if
you go back you see that big
yeah the building with the big spy she's
back in washington i guess so
store down here and check it out there's
a deli in the thrift store yeah
that building with the spires literally
if you go to the wikipedia
it's called the gridman building in
downtown ritzville
anything i don't think there's any bikes
or anything to be stolen by the bike
thieves
still doing that owen bit you know stole
my bike we should yeah
we should go move and take over
ritzville washington
because weed's legal there and there's
all these old buildings and we could
probably buy the whole city
owen's talking about thieves gays
dicks penis and anuses and stuff
hidden in plain sight guys look to be
fair i mean owen is a shitty comic but
he is still a comedian
so generally comedians
are going to have a hard time getting
through an entire show without making a
dick or a butt reference of course
i mean come on lady let's let's start
look we've all made our jokes about
owen and trust me we've we've shredded
owen on this show
um the thing is always something these
like ex-bears always try to like and i'm
like owen's a lot of things i don't
think he's i think crowder's gay
i don't think owen's gay i think owen's
a [ __ ] lunatic
huge penis means a big dick
closed oh
and then the uh oh they're only open on
the weekend oh oh oh oh are we gonna get
we have a
we have a face reveal
that's about what i expected her to look
like yeah that's not uh it kind of looks
like harvey dent
can he be trusted looks like what aaron
eckhart will look like in
25 years the weekends
and the dogs came out
cute in the store i wish i could have
videotaped them
dogs love me all animals love me well
because they don't have
a real sense of you know what your
babbling is
and then uh this is the newest one
this one is from today
peoples all around the world
how are you today
well here is my morning drink still
doing it
even though i'm living in my car on the
road again
um i bought a big bag of lemons at
costco
yesterday do you have scurvy yeah you
got to make sure you don't catch scurvy
if you're living in your car that's how
i heard you get it right it's a pirate
disease well yeah but they were living
in the
the old equivalent of your car fair
enough well it's just a car on water
it's okay i got a few things even though
they didn't want me to come in without
my mask
i was even escorted by a young man
a very tall young man i said this is
this a day he goes yep just me and you
he took me all the way to the back where
it was closed and got special permission
to go in
this is all accommodating me because i
won't wear a map
so what you're saying is you're
admitting gleefully
that you're a massive pain in the ass
and that by
by having to be a pain in the ass you're
now making a guy who probably doesn't
make a lot of money
makes 10 11 an hour now you're making
him work harder
you're making the entire store change
its [ __ ] around
just for you but keep telling me about
how your refusal to wear mask is heroic
work are you such a
i'm tired of people doing that like i'm
such a good person i won't wear a mask
and it's like
you're just making some shitty workers
day shittier like just let's do it man
i had to buy a mask i went out to eboor
friday night because i was helping my
buddy move and then it was like his last
night in towns i was we went out
and um i forgot my mask i had to pay
like five bucks for a mask at the bodega
because it's
it was either that or be a pain in the
ass and it was like uh
i it's on me i'm out five bucks because
i know the rules and i'd
but i did get a nice uh they got the
ones that they print on so i got a
little uh they had the
versace ones and they had like the
burberry ones
which one did you get i had a burberry
one because it matched what i was
wearing better
i don't even look at you they didn't
have plain white ones they the only ones
they add
u.s canadian border so there's my
lemonade drink i squeezed
the lemons into a jar put some maple
syrup in
then i went into a shell station
that sounds awful all of this is
terrible where they always have hot
water for coffee
and they let me take hot water for free
even though i offered to pay for it
and uh there's my drink nice and hot
nice and hot and ready to go that's my
break
fast i break my fast is
that what that means we know the origin
of the word lady is
that what that means each morning
there's nothing worse than the people
that share factoids everyone knows
but they'll be like did you know yes i
knew that
well here's a nice quiet serene sight
that is pretty wherever she's at look at
that
that is that is very pretty wherever
she's at oh it's amazing really nice
called levinsworth it has some close
high mountains it's oh it's the alps
the alps it's a fudge shop yeah it's
also washington a little germantown like
a little bavaria
look at all that beauty you see i took
the scenic route
[ __ ] a bunch of look man i love florida
and florida has a lot of things that are
very pretty and beautiful but
this stuff this i will i will admit that
i am
pacific northwest i am jealous of this
kind of stuff like this stuff's awesome
like the
how pretty it is there is is really nice
oh it's amazing the politics suck but